for a month now protests have rocked the
country which have left more than 20
people dead and thousands injured the
unrest began over a hike in metro fares
but quickly spun out of control devolve
into riots and looting kneecapping the
economy along the way as a result the
government promised to draft a new
constitution to replace the current one
president sebastián piñera also admitted
that security forces had met the
demonstrators with access force now
chile is considered one of Latin
America's strongest economies growth
this year is likely to be around two and
a half percent but inequality is a huge
problem just 1% of the population holds
nearly a quarter of the country's wealth
while the bottom half collectively just
owns 2% and they have very little chance
of escaping poverty now for more on the
story let's bring in a melinda meza from
Lancaster University good morning
ambolyn do good to have you on the
program
Chile had long been labeled as an
economic success story yet there is this
widespread inequality that we've talked
about tell us more about the root of
this problem when the constitution
disadvantaged a massive portion of the
country's population and that has been
going on for the last almost quarter of
a century what we have seen is that the
problem of the middle class it is an
aspirational middle class imagine going
to a shopping mall imagine being
surrounded by fancy restaurants but you
don't have the money in your wallet to
go and buy things or to have a lunch
there in these fancy restaurants that is
exactly what is happening in Chile
although we have a middle class it
simply doesn't have the purchasing power
and as you rightly put it in your report
earlier the country's richest 1% receive
33 percent of the country's income so
they have access to all the goodies
whereas the rest of the population
doesn't so that creates the massive
amount of unrest now a Melinda the
government has promised a constitution
overhaul is this the way out of this
crisis not necessarily because what we
have seen here is that a newly
neoliberal policy economic policy which
has kind of structurally disadvantaged a
massive portion of the population unless
and until we address that just having a
constitutional change doesn't go very
far let's say for example two different
sectors here one is education and the
other one is health care so if the
country doesn't invest in that if the
country doesn't open up those two
sectors to the middle class
the rising on the class so to speak then
the constitutional reform is not going
to go very far do you see any chances of
that happening these sectors being
opened up no what has happened here is
that exactly what we have in Mexico
because the rich grow richer and the
grow poorer and that is exactly what is
happening in Chile it is a success story
yes but it is a success story only for
only a specific section of the society
if you look at the OECD figures Chile
sits at the bottom in terms of economic
disparity the gap that we talked about
earlier so unless and until we address
the specific structural readjustment
then the discontent is going to continue
and whatever kind of window dressing we
are going to do so this constitutional
reform is not going to address the real
questions at the ground level
a melinda meza from Lancaster University
thank you for your thoughts